meanwhile White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders earlier broke major news
about President Trump summit with the
North Korean dictator little rocket man
Kim jong-un next week in Singapore take
a listen
I can tell you the president has been
receiving daily briefings on North Korea
from his national security team and I
can also tell you the schedule or
tentatively for that first meeting will
be on June 12th at 9 a.m. Singapore time
and take place at June 11th 9 p.m. East
Coast time no matter what you called you
use maximum pressure still the policy of
the United States to our home country
our policy hasn't changed and as the
President stated we have sanctions on
they're very powerful and we would not
take those sanctions off unless North
Korea denuclearize
right here with reaction is White House
press secretary Sarah Sanders who joins
us Sarah good to see you thank you
always for being back with us so from my
perspective this is really simple about
North Korea so far we know that one
nuclear test site is shut down we know
that he crossed the DMZ he released
three American hostages he's willing to
talk about denuclearization and as far
as I know the United States and the
president haven't paid a dime for any of
that true true look the president has
conceded nothing and the sanctions that
have been on place will continue to be
in place but as the president said on
Friday this is part of the discussion
and he looks forward to this meeting and
he thinks that it's going to be a very
good and productive meeting and it's
gonna be part of this process but he
certainly thinks that June 12th is going
to be a good meeting and he's certainly
looking forward to doing that here in
the next week you know I I think the
president also is very smart and trying
to manage expectations nothing is going
to be signed next week and this will go
as fast or slow as North Korea wants the
sanctions remain in place if there's
another missile fired we know that the
president would then probably send our
strike forces right back off the Korean
Peninsula if need be so it seems that
especially when the president pulled out
for a period that he means what he says
and he is willing to walk away at any
time
100% the president is extremely serious
about this process and ultimately he
wants to see denuclearization of the
peninsula that's the that's the top goal
here and that's what he's focused on
doing that's what the talks next week
will center on but he also knows that as
he said this may this may take time this
may not happen over the course of one
meeting but several meetings and this is
the beginning of that dialogue and the
president is going to be committed and
firm to it and as he has said we'll see
what happens but he has good feeling
about how this first meeting will go
okay that amazing thing is and I
understand how the media is so the
president has kept all of his promises
on getting rid of burdensome regulation
largest tax cuts in American history
that promise is fulfilled moving the
country towards energy independence you
could see the president's fighting on
all issues regarding the border in the
wall I know it's 500 days and that he
kept his word on Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel pulling out of the
Iranian deal nobody really expected that
it started out as a little rocket man
this would happen and I and I watch you
every day and I watched you today and
all the focus was well you told us in
2017 that the president had nothing to
do with the comments of Don junior and
I'm thinking well every report shows
that what the president said that the
Magnitsky Act or the fact that that
meeting was all about and all the emails
prove it to be about talking about
adoption that the fact is at the end of
that report is they told the truth isn't
that the bigger picture that is missed
tonight certainly that's one of the big
things missed tonight but I think the
biggest story that's being missed
tonight and I saw it today in that room
they asked me a hundred questions on the
fake witch-hunt that they have been
fixated on for these last 500 days but
they forgot to mention the things that
Americans actually care about like the
booming economy we have the best economy
since we've had we've had since World
War two and they refuse to talk about
that the stock market is growing people
actually have jobs people that need jobs
and want jobs
can get them I mean the fact that that
wasn't something that was talked about
that wasn't brought up that was totally
ignored the fact that Isis is on the run
and being defeated day after day and
we're in a much better position than
ever before when it comes to that battle
the fact that the president has
completely remade the judiciary the fact
that we are becoming an energy
independent in an energy dominant
country under this president's
leadership they ignore all of the
successes of this president and it's to
their detriment and I think the American
people have seen it and that's why the
media's numbers continue to tank and the
president's numbers continue to go up
Sarah Huckabee Sandra's thanks for being
with us